we spent some time talking about
hydrocarbons and hydrocarbons are
interesting especially if you want to
combust things if you want some fuel but
now we're going to make things a little
bit more interesting by adding things to
the hydrocarbons and the things we're
going to add we call functional groups
functional
groups and my goal in this video is to
give you an overview of the major
functional groups that you might see
attached to carbon backbones that make
the molecules interesting biologically
now the first one i will focus on is an
oh group so you have an oh attached to a
carbon backbone over here it doesn't
have to be attached to a carbon backbone
but the oh right over here this is
called a hydroxyl group
high
hydroxyl group and when it is attached
to a carbon backbone like this one is
then it turns the entire molecule into
an alcohol
alcohol this is an alcohol and this one
in particular if you want the name we
have two carbons on along its longest
chain and it is an alcohol so we use the
prefix f for the two carbons so let me
write that down we're going to use the
prefix f because we have two carbons
here and we're going to say ethanol now
what are the properties here well you
have oxygen which is very
electronegative bonded to a hydrogen and
to a carbon but the oxygen is a lot more
electronegative than the hydrogen so
you're going to have a partially
negative charge at this end away from
the hydrogen a partial positive charge
at the hydrogen end and to a lesser
degree at the carbon end too but
hydrogen is even less electron is is
less electronegative than even carbon
and so this one so a hydroxyl group they
are polar
they are polar and because they're polar
you can dissolve them into into water
they are hydrophilic they can form
hydrogen bonds so you can dissolve this
now a similar a similar
functional group or one that has
somewhat similar properties is right
over here and you might say wait why is
this one similar i have a i have sulfur
here instead of oxygen but if you look
at the periodic table you will see that
sulfur and oxygen both have six valence
electrons they both would love nothing
more to than to grab or pretend to grab
two other electrons and this is why they
form they tend to form two covalent
bonds and so this group right over here
which is called a sulfhydryl group
this is a
self
sulfhydryl
group it's it's kind of similar to a
hydroxyl group with the one difference
with the one difference that sulfur is
electronegative but it is less
electronegative than oxygen so you're
still going to have a partially negative
charge and a partially positive charge
but it's going to be less polar so it's
not quite as polar as if you had a
hydroxyl group now when you have this
sulfhydryl group it's attached to say a
carbon chain and when i when i use this
r right over here when i have this r
this is just shorthand for carbon and a
bunch of other stuff i could have if i
wanted to generalize an alcohol right
over here i could have written r
and then i could have written the
hydroxyl group o
and then bond that
bond that to an h so over here this
shorthand r would have been the
shorthand for all of the r would have
been the shorthand for all of this
business
all of this business right over here and
so that's what we're doing over there
i'm not saying that this r is exactly
this it means it's some you know carbon
backbone and some and carbons hydrogens
and maybe other stuff maybe even some
other functional groups but we're just
focused on the sulfhydryl right over
here and so if you see something like
this you say okay yeah this is still
going to be polar but not quite as polar
as if i were dealing with a hydroxyl
group
now over here we have a more complex
molecule but this is a molecule that you
run into probably on a daily basis
this is the sugar fructose
this is the sugar
fructose and this is this is when it is
not in a ring if you were to throw this
into if you were to throw this into
water it'll readily form a ring but when
it's not in a ring form you can
recognize already the hydroxyl groups
you have a hydroxyl group on this carbon
hydroxyl group on this carbon you have a
hydroxyl group on that carbon you have a
hydroxyl group on this carbon and then
on this carbon you it's double bonded to
an oxygen we call this a carbonyl group
so this is a
this is a carbonyl
carbonyl
carbonyl group and this is actually how
you would tell sugar it's like look
especially when it said a straight chain
all my carbons have a hydra have one
hydroxyl on them except for this one it
has a carbonyl group
and one of the takeaways for a carbonyl
group we've already talked about oxygen
being very electronegative even more
electronegative than carbon it's double
bonds it's going to hog the electrons on
the oxygen end so you're going to have a
partial you're going to have a partially
negative charge
partially negative charge over here
partially positive charge over here and
so this this one is also going to be
polar and then in fact the entire
molecule is very polar because it has
all these hydroxyl groups on it as well
but this is also going to give it
polarity here and because this carbon
has a slightly positive charge it is
susceptible to nucleophilic attack and
when you take organic chemistry you'll
see that things that that want to want
to share that that have a predisposition
to to share their electrons in a bond
might want to come and and form a bond
with this carbon and maybe one of these
these electron pairs go back to this go
back to this oxygen maybe bond with
something else but we'll talk about that
in the future when we study some organic
chemistry mechanisms the important thing
to hear is just recognize okay i've got
some hydroxyl groups hey i got a
carbonyl group right over here as well
now this molecule this is an amino acid
and you will see amino acids a lot when
you study biology and this has actually
a couple of interesting groups on it the
first group of note is this is this
stuff that i am circling in orange
because you have a carbon that is you
could say it's part of a carbonyl group
but it is also it is also bound to a
hydroxyl group it is also bound to a
hydroxyl group right over there and when
you have this configuration where you
have a carbon bond double bonded to an
oxygen and then single bonded to a
hydroxyl group we call this a carboxyl
group
this is a
car carboxyl
carboxyl
carboxyl group
and one of the takeaways from this is
that it is acidic because this can
readily give up the hydrogen proton this
oxygen we already know oxygen likes to
hog electrons it can take up both of
these electrons and become negative and
actually there's actually resonance here
because those electrons get shared
throughout the group and actually even
potentially even beyond the group but
especially inside of the group
then leaving the hydrogen proton so this
can readily donate a hydrogen this can
readily donate a hydrogen proton so this
is generally viewed as acidic
acidic
now this this this amino acid over here
it also and this is where this name
comes from actually the acid comes from
this carboxyl group that's the acidic
part and then you have an amino group
you have an amino group
right
over here
and because it's involving nitrogen this
is the amino group this is what gives
the amino part of the name amino acid
amino acid and this is actually
generally basic because nitrogen could
it has a lone pair it has a it has a
lone pair of electrons right over here
and so it could use that lone pair to
pick up to to form a bond with a with a
hydrogen ion to pick up a hydrogen ion
so under the right circumstances it can
form a bond with a hydrogen ion which we
know a positive ion which would just be
a proton and so it would have a positive
charge and so since it can sop up
hydrogen ions we can view this as the
amino group as being basic but this
right over here is leucine it's an amino
acid super important for muscle growth
but there you there there you can
appreciate you have
essentially a hydrocarbon chain but it
has a carboxyl group at this end and an
amino group right over here another
thing that you'll sometimes people talk
about is even hydrocarbon groups for
example if you consider the main chain
of this and we could consider it either
using this carbon or this carbon but if
we consider this to be the main chain
of carbons
if we consider that to be the main chain
of carbons then we would consider this
right over here to be a methyl group
remember the prefix meth refers to one
carbon so it's one carbon bonded to a
bunch of hydrogens to three hydrogens
here and so we would call this a methyl
group
and in general if you have a hydrocarbon
bonded to other hydrocarbon groups these
things are are hydrophobic so these
things there's nothing polar about them
and so they're not going to want to at
least this parts these parts of the
molecules are not going to naturally
dissolve inside of water now the last
group we're going to focus on you're
going to see a lot of these and
especially in biology you're going to
see it as part of atp you're going to
see this a backbone of dna and that's
phosphate groups
and this right over here
this right over here is the phosphate
group
i've drawn it bonded to a bunch of uh
kind of a a group over here who knows
what it is a bunch of carbons a bunch of
other things and then i've modded it to
two hydrogens but it doesn't always have
to be bound to hydrogens but what it is
bound to hydrogens like this is
considered to be pro it's protonated and
so it can actually take up it can
actually hog these electrons and dump
these hydrogens and dump these hydrogens
into a solution so a phosphate group is
considered to be acidic
it is considered as well especially when
it is protonated like this it is
considered to be acidic because it can
donate protons so this is just an
overview of a lot of the functional
groups you will see throughout biology
and a lot of big hairy complex molecules
when you actually break it down you say
okay there's a hydrocarbon chain there
oh i see a sugar there i see a bunch of
hydroxyls and i have a carbonyl group oh
i see an amine group i see an amino
group i see a carbox a carboxyl group
you can think about is this going to be
acidic is it going to be polar or do
different parts of the molecules have
different functions